sabotage occupation destruction les
Français n'en peuvent plus de ces
écologistes radicaux dont les méthodes
visent à tout saccager un jour il
détruisent des antennes 5G un autre ce
sont des œuvres d'art dans des musées
nationaux ou encore les sièges
d'entreprise qu'ils accusent de salir la
planète jusqu'à se retrouver aujourd'hui
dans le viseur du ministère de
l'Intérieur le dernier épisode de
vandalisme remonte au 15 juin lorsque
deux militantes ont badigeonné de rouge
le jardin de l'artiste Giverny un
chef-d'oeuvre de Claude Monet prêté par
le Musée d'Orsay au National Museum à
Stockholm 88% des Français condamnent ce
genre d'action pareil pour les sabotages
d'infrastructures et d'exploitation
agricoles 85% des Français les rejettent
comment décembre 2022 lorsqu’une
centaine de casseurs en combinaison
blanche ont dévasté la cimenterie
Lafarge de Provence et dans la foulée
des destructions de cerf à
Pont-Saint-Martin en juin et l'épisode
des méga bastines à Sainte Soline le 25
mars le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald
Darmanin a annoncé la création d'une
cellule antisades avec des juristes
spécialisés autre signe de ce ras-le-bol
généralisé 73% des Français se disent
même convaincus que les services de
renseignement doivent pouvoir utiliser
les mêmes moyens que terrorisme pour
surveiller et arrêter les activistes qui
comptent saboter les sites sensibles que
mes propos ne soient pas mal interprétés
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique est un combat légitime qui
mérite d'être mené avec détermination
mais avec les moyens admis en démocratie
or ce qui a très nettement été documenté
à Sainte Soline c'est que cette
revendication constitue pour certains un
prétexte pour s'en prendre au symbole de
l'État aux forces de l'ordre à ce qu'ils
appellent le système au capital et à
tous ceux qui le représentent pour
enrayer ce phénomène huit Français sur
dix jugent donc il serait efficace de
déployer en permanence des agents de
sécurité d'installer davantage de
caméras mais aussi de mieux payer et
mieux former les agents de certains
sites industriels et si ces modes
d'action choc cela ne signifie pas que
les Français sont insensibles aux
questions de l'écologie puisque plus de
trois quarts d'entre eux partagent la
volonté des mouvements écologistes de
lutter contre le dérèglement climatique
[Musique]